hello and welcome everybody um
this today's webinar is about the easy
to connect
our latest instrument for sample
purification
my name is jan schulz and i'm heading
the global product management team for
sample prep
automation um here at kyogen
and with me today is jessica
yes hello everybody so my name is
jessica there and i'm a scientific
expert and working in the instrument
robotics department at kyagen
and i was involved in the development of
the ec2
thank you jessica
today we will have a look at the
automation market
we will look um why it is required what
are the current
challenges in research and how can
automation provide a solution
and then we will look into the easy one
and the ev2
the history of the ez-1 family and what
additional benefits
the ev2 can bring to address the
challenges
scientific progress changed the
requirements
um on laboratories um we see with our
customers
um that they need to isolate nucleic
acids
for more and more challenging sample
materials like soil
how to live microbes or sometimes they
even have only traces
um or they are facing various amounts of
nucleic acid in their sample material at
the same time
they need to subject um these nucleic
acids to
um very diverse downstream applications
like
pcr qpcr and more and more
ngs and also digital pcr bringing
new um challenges and new requirements
to the nucleic assets
so these are different difficulties that
we see
in research um because of this
challenging sample materials
we are facing a huge experimental
variation
um and and increased challenges
with the sample types which which have
impact on the
on the sensitivity also of the
downstream application
our customers are facing on sometimes a
huge number
of samples that need to be processed
at the same time we have very expensive
downstream applications
like ngs and this reduces the budget
also
for each individual experiment um
we have um a demand for traceability
which means
um that customers are working in a
regulated
surrounding and therefore need to
document all the steps that they are
doing
we have many centralized laboratories
which means that you need
to coordinate the work on on instruments
often
multiple groups or many groups are
working
with single instruments and even in one
lab
multiple users are working on one
instrument and
we have in single labs multiple
workflows
um that are conducted and how can we
address this um
with automation um the
high variability that operators see
can be addressed by taking away the menu
of steps so we want to have
a high degree of automation which
then automatically um in a low variation
of the
of the results and then we want um a set
to minimize the hands-on procedure not
only to limit
the variability but also
to allow to process large number of
samples
um we want to make the lab more
efficient
and thereby we want to reduce the cost
per prep
and also if you reduce the variability
of the experiment
it takes less experiments to get to a
significant result
we can support the traceability
of experiments we have with automation
the option to track operations and
to track um who conducted the experiment
the lot number of kits and so on and so
on
and in the end of course it's also about
flexibility
one instrument needs to be able
to conduct various workflows
with the ev1 we have been very
successful
in the market and we placed thousands of
instruments
since its launch in 2003 and customers
really
appreciated um the instruments because
it is a very reliable
and a robust instrument and um
it's also a very fast instrument we have
customers that you
use it as a high throughput instrument
putting multiple
instruments next to each other to
perform one sample after the other
the kit's performance is very reliable
and customers
appreciate the technology of the
instrument it's it's a very robust
technology and this is shown here
so what the instrument is doing um is
that it
works with tips inside so it really can
aspirate liquid and with the liquid
also the magnetic beads and then a
magnet
can be put in close proximity to this
tip
to attract um the beads and the liquid
can be exchanged and also transferred
then to the next well
and so on and so on and um this is very
unusual for an
instrument in this size normally bench
top instruments
work with static magnets and um
only transferring the the liquid by
keeping uh the
particles um in one well and here we can
transfer
we even can add liquid um in in one well
which allows for a higher degree or a
maximal degree i would even say
of automation
so with the ev1 set we have been very
successful
and customers appreciate um the the
system and the performance and the
process safety
um but of course we um we want also to
deliver
new solutions and to um to adapt also to
the newer requirements of the markets
that i already introduced
you to and um so we talked to to the
customers into the different customer
groups that we already have
um with the ev1 and ask them
about their requirements and what they
told us is
that they need a higher throughput um
and
also an adaption of the kit portfolio so
we need
newer kits we need kits that are
designed to cope
with sample types that are currently
required and are of process um also we
have customers that want to
work with larger volumes and
uh being able to um to use them
also with a benchtop instrument um we
want to expand this scope of automation
so we want to have a higher degree of
automation
um custom asset we want to reduce
the manual steps in the workflow and we
want to keep the instruments very simple
this is
of course true for the maintenance um
but also for the usability
so what we came up with is with an
approach where we
don't where we will not launch a single
instrument because
for our different customer groups um
this would not be enough and would not
be tailored
um for the customer groups but we will
have three different instruments
this is the easy to connect for our
customers in life science research this
is a kind of
basic um variant i would say and then we
have
two instrument variants that are
tailored for customers working in
forensics this is
easy to connect fx for forensics and the
easy to connect mdx
for customers working in medical
diagnostics
and they come with some special features
but today we will focus
on the ev2 connect for customers in
life science research and with that i
hand over to jessica
yes for now it's my turn to proudly
present to use the easy to connect
so as a header already summarizes and
summarizes very well
is that simplicity safety and speed this
is what the easy to connect is all about
so let me tell you a bit more about its
features
so we already started with a wide kit
portfolio from the easy one and we
transferred this portfolio of course to
the ev2
but development of the ez2 allowed us to
increase the rate of
sample input materials even more and
then we'll
present you in a bit already some new
clips that we have in development
the easy two guarantees maximal process
safety because our reaction cartridges
they are pre-filled and sealed
under the ui conditions and this means
that they also stay sealed until you
have prepared your run
you have loaded everything to the
instrument and then
just press the start button we have an
onboard piercing mechanism that will
then
will do the complete job for you so
there's no manual interference necessary
another great thing about the easy to
connect is that we are
able to minimize hands on time even more
so we have several modules on board
that are needed for efficient nuclear
nucleic acid purification
for example like i already mentioned
before the piercing bar
we also have an onboard pipetting system
a movable magnet
that can collect the beads during the
purification
and we have also heating and cooling
system
so with this we can we were able to
minimize the pre-treatment
requirements and maximize level of
automation
and please keep in mind that this is
still a benchtop instrument
so the ez2 has also flexible input we
scaled up a bit
so you can now process up to 24 samples
in parallel maybe one of the most
striking improvements
is a huge touch display so with the ev2
we now have a
graphic user interface phase which will
guide you through the run setup
and also through the maintenance
procedure so we do not need to
use those protocol cards anymore we know
from the easy one
because the instrument now comes with
pre-installed protocols
which means that as soon the instrument
arrives at your left you can just
unpack it put it on a bench plug it in
and it is ready to go
we also have a clear hood which is also
a very nice feature
because we can follow the process step
by step and this is also very great for
training purposes
additionally we have a led stripe at the
top of the instrument
and this enhanced visibility of the work
table
and we can also use this for um yeah
visualization of the instrument status
this means if a one is finished
we have a very slow blinking and if we
have an
error on the instrument we have a bit
faster thinking
this means that even from far away you
can also see what the instrument status
is all about
um and you might already have noticed
that we have equipped the ec2
also with the connectivity feature which
might be suggested already by the name
easy to connect
um this means that we can connect the
instrument to the kaya sphere base
so the internet of things is a huge
topic at the moment
and i guess nowadays it's really hard to
buy even a washing machine without this
feature so um i will get back to this
feature later and i will show you all
the benefits that we have with our
connectivity feature
so let's summarize how the easy to can
improve your daily lab routine so there
are only three
simple steps needed from your sample to
high
quality nuclear efforts so you just have
to load the sample and the cartridge
into the instrument
then you can run a pre
pre-programmed protocol and if you need
or if you want to use this we also have
a guided run setup here
then you just have to start and press
the start button
and then you can watch the instrument do
its job so this might be really relaxing
but
if you don't have the time to do that
you can also just leave
so with our connectivity feature you
will be able to
have a look at the run progress and also
the status of the instrument from your
mobile device and you can choose if you
would like to have notifications which
means that you just
can do whatever you are up to and get a
push notification as soon as the
instrument is done
so to increase flexibility even more we
also have
extended our tip rack portfolio so the
basic instrument will come with a basic
tip rack
and this can be used for screw cap tubes
and also for tip holders with tip
so you can put the tubes and tip holes
at each put
at gear at each position and the
protocol will guide you
what to put at which position if you
would like to use
clip cap tubes with this rack we also
have a special rack now it's the flip
cap tip rack
um and here you can see this is a
picture in the middle
so you can put tubes with tip holders in
the middle row
and we also have special slots for the
flip cap tubes
in the front and also in the back row
additionally we have the newest number
to our wax family
which is a large volume tip rack and you
can see that this one has enlarged
positions in the middle
so these can hold large volume tools and
these large volume tubes
will hold up to eight mil for tubes
which is really great
and for example this one is really
amazing if you want
to purify really low abundance dna and
rna
and then we'll already show you later
that we also have
application for this one in place
okay thank you um now we are coming to
the
to the kids and i said we already have
an extensive
portfolio of kips for the easy one this
is shown on the
on the left side uh where we um have uh
kits
um to process uh different volumes of
blood
we have tissue kits for dna rna and also
virus kits and
and also some ccf dna kits
but we will come up with a new kit
portfolio already launched
now in in april and in may
and these are what called easy one and
two kits and as a name indicates
these will be compatible with the easy
one and also with the easy
two um these are the easy one and two
dna ffpe kit and the easy one and two
dna ffpe
ung kits and we will talk about these
um in the next slides and then there
will also be the easy one and two ccf
dna kit
which we also look at um
in today's webinar and jessica already
told us about
um the new um tip racks that are used
for this
and we will also come up with additional
tips
um launching in october which are called
easy two kits and this
also already indicates that they are
used only on the easy
two um and these include kits for
isolating
mrna from circulating tumor cells we
will have
a kit for micro rna isolation and we
will
also complete our ffpe product portfolio
with a kit for
rna isolation and the kit for
simultaneous dna
and rna isolation from ffpe
and i said we now will continue with the
easy one and to dna ffpe kit
and with the challenges when processing
ffpe and for
for those of you who already did that
they uh are familiar with that
um there are multiple challenges uh when
um
dealing with ffpe samples on one end we
have
um various storage times
um so that means that that some
um of some labs are facing ffpe samples
that have been um in in the basement for
about 10 years 20 years or whatever some
are using very fresh ffps materials
and this is a challenge when you develop
a kit
to develop a solution that can cope with
all of these
and then we have the fixation
procedure itself we are facing different
fixation times there are different
protocols to do the fixation some
labs do this only for a few minutes and
some
have the samples
put in formalin um for for hours days
and even months or years um and
this goes along with the cross-linking
the fixation the aim of the fixation
itself
is to crosslink proteins within
the tissue but it also cross-links the
dna to the proteins
and and vice versa and this of course is
good when you want to fix the tissue
but it becomes difficult when you want
to extract dna from a tissue
and if you do so you will also face the
fragmentation of the dna
um so the whole um fixation and
dehydration procedure puts a lot of
stress on the dna
and it will become fragmented and then
there are some affects
as well when you fix a tissue informally
you will generate artifact
within the dna and we will come to this
now with the next slide
so what happens um to a sample and to
the dna within the sample
uh when you fix it in in formalin is
depicted here
um cytosine normally
um binds to guanine and
here it is shown that the fixation
uh deaminates the cytosine and it
becomes a uracil and this
uracil then um doesn't uh
bind to guanine anymore but
to adenium and what does that mean um
for the sequencing of the sample which
is depicted here
on the left hand you see
the the original dna before fixation
and then with fixation the cytosine
becomes deaminated and to uracil
depicted in red and if you now do the
pcr amplification during ndf library
press
this uracil will then bind um to adenine
which would normally not be there
because um the
the cytosine that was originally there
would bind to
guanine and then the adenine in the next
step
would bind to timidine so when we look
and compare the first the original
sequence
uh with the region with the sequence
that is then sequenced in the end
you see that there's a transition from
cytosine to timing and from guanine
to adenine which is which is wrong then
and
um we can help and and we we do this
with a new kit
um to remove these edge effects um we
have the option
to do a ung treatment which stands for
uracil and glycosylase
and this removes the uracil in the first
step
and thereby prevents the wrong
analysis here the other challenge
when working with ffpe samples and
if you want to isolate dna from these is
that it is a very long procedure
and automation is not not that easy
and normally um instruments
um are used to automate only
the last steps of this whole procedure
so the bind
wash elute steps but now with the easy
two
we have we have the option
to automate the full process which means
after the paraffinization
we have a lysis step with and
the cross-linking step which is very um
very important to remove the fixation
cost crosslinks and then we can do the
ung step
so with optional artifact removal step
which can also be automated um then we
have an rna removal step
and a second lysis step which which
optimizes the performance and
and increases the yield and
everything all of these steps can be
automated then
on the easy to connect we also offer um
an another protocol which also which
only automates the bindwash illusion
steps this can also be done
on the on the easy one but full
automation is also possible
than on the eb2 um we did this
and subjected ffpe samples from various
um human organs to the procedure so
isolating it
with the easy one into dna ffpe kit and
also with a semi-automated competitor
kit
and afterwards we measured the amount of
double-stranded dna
within the within the alloys and what is
quite obvious
and for those of you who worked already
with ffpe samples and especially
with samples from different organs um
that we
see a huge variation with respect
um to the amount of dna
um that you can isolate from these
samples but
um this is uh this is normal um and and
this is
um what you normally see when you're
when you do this with different organs
but what is also obvious is
that we have always a high content of
double stranded dna
when we isolate with the easy one and
two dna ffbe kit
and we also subjected this dna to
downstream qpcr
analysis and remember that this is
the polymerase chain reaction this means
that the dna
just doubled in every cycle of this
reaction
and it counts the cycle
when the amount of dna has reached a
certain
threshold that means that the lower the
c cq value here
um the better and it indicates more dna
is is
in the sample and also here we see that
we have
high amounts of amplifiable dna
uh when we isolate this different
tissues
with the easy one into dna ffpe kit
and i already introduced you to the
to the ung step and this is shown here
actually we isolated dna from a colon
cancer sample with a noun sequence
and then we compared um the sequencing
result
to the original sequence and we did this
the isolation one time with the with the
ung
treatment and also without ung treatment
and what you see here is a comparison of
acg or t
of the amount of these bases um compared
to the c in the reference sample and
when we do this
without a ung treatment
indicated by the blue bars you see that
there's an increase of
timing so of teeth within the reeds
clearly indicating an artifact
with the d elimination
and the appearance of uracil when we do
this with ung
digestion up front indicated by the red
bars
the number of teeth correlated to seeds
in the reference
becomes then normal and the same is true
when we do this for adenine compared
to g in the reference where we see
an increase of a's when we
do not do the ung digestion in blue on
the right side
but when we do this indicated by the red
bars
it becomes again normal and goes to a
normal level
clearly showing the performance of the
ung
treatment so in total we can say that
we here can offer a solution
with the easy one into dna ffpe kit
where you can isolate dna
from challenging sspe samples with a
minimum
time and a maximum degree of automation
with high performance and even offer
an additional ung treatment to get rid
of
of fixation aspect making it an
optimal solution for ffpe processing in
an automated way
another very challenging sample material
is liquid biopsy and
the um the standard
key analyte when it comes to liquid
biopsy
is cell free dna but this also comes
along
with certain challenges so the amount of
cell-free dna
within a plasma sample is very very low
and also very variable it can range from
1 to 50
nanograms per milliliter of
blood sample and in addition um this is
also
masked by other dnas in this sample
during transportation and also during
storage
um samples or cells within the sample
can release
their own dna into the plasma
and this will mask on the dna that is
there and also we have
cell free dna from the host which
can be um then the yeah
the normal the healthy cells so to say
when we are searching for cell free dna
from tumors
or it can also be the mother for example
when we are searching for cell free dna
from the fetus um and this makes
the processing and uh yeah the isolation
very difficult because we need a very
very sensitive
method to isolate the cell-free dna
and with to achieve maximal sensitivity
we needed to find a way
to process large volumes of
a sample on a benchtop instrument
which is very uncommon and very
challenging
and here we use the new tip racks that
jessica introduced to you
and this allows us to process up to
eight milliliters
of sample to isolate cell free dna
making it a very very sensitive
um isolation um
and also a very efficient isolation
we have run times on average of 45
minutes
whereas this is calculated as an average
for eight milliliters the instrument
would only need
76 minutes in total for 24 samples
um when you process less for example 2
milliliters
the instrument is faster than it takes
only 35
minutes for 24 samples
this slide shows an experiment that we
did
in our research and development
department here we used the easy one and
two
ccf dna kit and a competitor kit to
isolate
cell-free dna from four milliliter edta
plasma
and what is quite obvious is that we
reach
a higher yield with a easy one and two
selfie dna kit
compared to the competitor for both
samples
showing that it is the high performance
of the kit and um indicating the maximum
sensitivity
that you can reach in downstream
applications
so um so far from the new kids and now i
will hand over to jessica again
um to talk more about the easy to
connect
instrument
so now it's time to keep my promise and
tell you a bit more about our
connectivity feature
with the kaya strong instrument
again please no problem just give it a
few seconds you can start again
so now it's time to keep my promise and
tell you a bit more about our
connectivity feature so with the easy to
connect you have the option to connect
your instrument to the kayaking cloud
or you can use the functionalities in
local mode
access to the kaiasv app is also really
flexible
you can use a desktop app on your pc but
we also have mobile versions
for android and also ios devices
available
and one example of these mobile view you
can see here in the picture
in the app we have a bunch of
functionalities available
you can see all instruments that you
have connected to the kiosk base
in an overview you can keep track of
your instruments and also the status of
each and every instrument via real-time
tracking and
with the status monitor you can of
course also get push notifications which
i already mentioned before
and these are customizable so you can
select what you would like to be
notified on
we also have a maintenance viewer in
place and you can download run reports
via app we also notify you about
upcoming updates and you can update them
remotely with one click so this is
really
easy and convenient we also have an
instrument scheduler
and a usage monitor in place and
with this you can manage your instrument
and also work with from anywhere at any
time
and everything can be done really
effortless without even having to be in
the lab
and speaking about effortlessness this
also applies to our maintenance
procedure
so here in the picture you can see
the uv decontamination so you can see
that we have an old
we have a high emission uv lamp in place
you can see here's a little reflector
and the status led 4 which is a safety
feature for the uv led lamp and in
addition to the usual q
clean up procedure we can do a
decontamination of the work deck
using this uv led and this is also
automated so you just have to go to the
maintenance section of your
user interface and select some cycles
you would like to run
and then start the procedure
so with this we are already on our last
slide
and i hope that you share our excitement
for the easy to connect
so let me briefly summarize what we have
learned today
the easy to connect raises the bar for
workflow automation
we have on deck piercing we have online
pipetting we have a heating module
and also a cooling functionality and the
magnet bar in place
so this really allows you to minimize
pre-treatment steps
and maximize with automation
for bigger process safety we have
pre-filled cartridges
and this will increase the um also the
rear possibility of
the nuclear asset purification and last
but not least like i already introduced
to you a few slides ago we have the
connectivity feature
so this will enable you to monitor and
manage your instrument from anywhere
anytime
with any desktop or mobile device
so thank you for your attention and
don't hesitate to contact us if you
want to have more information about the
easy to connect
or you want to see it live in your lab
or to get more information material
thanks a lot for your attention
and now it's time for questions please
don't hesitate
to come up with ideas questions or
just feedback